hi everybody my name is Marco Crowell
I'm a Canada Research Chair in an air
chemistry of dementia and I'll be
talking to you about some of the
technologies that we've developed in the
last few years to evaluate cognition in
mouse models of disease we're interested
in particular in Alzheimer's disease and
dementia and and my talk is going to
focus on that and also I what I'm want
to do is to really advocate for this new
movie or this it's not so new but this
movement on open science where data
becomes available for reuse we analysis
and and and validation and which we have
developed a new repository and I would
like to talk to you about this so it's
really the you know an overarching theme
of my presentation is going to be
reproducibility we're using techniques
that we think are very reproducible
between different labs and we have
actually tested that for behavior
analysis and and also advancing
evaluation of mouse models of disease
towards the goal of using these mouse
models to facilitate drug discovery and
it's really a you know there is some
some major issues in drug discovery and
if you think about Alzheimer's disease
there is not being a drug that is being
approved in the last 20 years and and
and the same thing with other forms of
other types of dementia and this is just
to give you an idea of the really long
process that it is to develop a drug
where you start from the basic very
basic level with the screening of maybe
10,000 different compounds you go and
test preclinically in cells and animal
models this takes between five to seven
years maybe then you start getting the
regulatory bodies on board you know if
you think you have a good candidate and
you go to bring culture bios there's no
a very large number of people evolved
and
eventually this may show some
improvement which has not happened in
the field of Alzheimer's disease and for
the last 20 years and and you have a new
compound that you know benefit cognition
Asami's disease
so one of the issues that happens is
that this translation there is a huge
translation gap between the preclinical
work and clinical trials in the number
of drugs that have been validated and
animal models of disease they really
when they get to clinical trials they
don't show any benefit and and so this
is one of the aspects that my group and
a number of my colleagues are are
tackling right now and trying to develop
ways that we can more faithfully
understand what this preclinical testing
are telling us and maybe do a better job
of vetting the drugs that goes and move
to clinical trials so this is the the
one of the issues that we are attacking
and there is many different many
different aspects on these issues for
example there is no number numbers of
animal models and that you can use to
test for drugs and that's the main
problem how do you project which is
drugs to improve cognitive symptoms
using animal models and what would be
the best animal models for specific
types of symptoms and more importantly
what is the best way to test cognition
in design among models that will be
helped to translate these findings from
the preclinical to the clinical the
clinical testing so these are just some
of the diseases that can cause the
mainship in all nervous diseases
obviously the main cause of the mainship
but there is a number of visit this is
you know a parts of disease that can
also dementia as well there's a number
of rare prion diseases to that is very
fast developing dementia
I'm eutrophic lateral sclerosis can it
is really a continue between a grip of
lateral sclerosis and frontotemporal
dementia which is again cause a number
of cognitive problem wants to put let's
make it clear that's what the main
complains of patients is really when
they start losing cognition and in this
different disease there are different
types of protein misfolding in terms of
alzheimer's disease we know that
it's really a combination of genetic and
five style factors that contributed your
risk of the disease but genetics play an
important role there's a number of genes
that that have small effects but can
increase your risk of developing
Alzheimer's disease and before is is the
most prevalent gene less than 1% of the
case a really familiar forms of
Alzheimer's disease which what I mean by
that is saying that these are people
that develop Alzheimer's disease very
early because they have mutations that
and with those mutations you develop
Alzheimer's disease and those mutations
and a specific pathway in the brain that
we're going to go through there is a
number of different hallmarks from
synaptic dysfunction to this function of
the cholinergic nervous system other
neurotransmitters are affected but
logically you have this accumulation of
plaques and their February tangles in
the brain and obviously Neri formation
has received a lot of attention in the
last few years and this ow
contribute to cognitive failure and this
is just a cartoon that I took from the
NIH web page showing that you know the a
cartoon representing the changes in the
brain with with Alzheimer's disease and
and the other side you have the
processing of the amyloid persue problem
through a better Secretary's way that is
a minute egg generates peptides from one
to forty two one two forty-three amino
acids and one forty and this
ties tend to aggregate they can be
diffusible like all of ours and they're
already toxic but then they accumulate
in those plaques those so-called extra
stellar plaques and this seems to
trigger hyper phosphorylation of tau
that cause Alzheimer's that that will
contribute to Alzheimer's disease and
this near February tangles so if you
think about animal models of Alzheimer's
disease there is a number of those
models that have been developed most of
the animal models that have been
developed they are transgenic mice
models of Alzheimer's disease they use
the used mutations of the amyloid
protein or present allene which is one
of the components of the gamma secretase
pathway and reproduce those mutations
found the humans in mice and obviously
the idea is that if you can improve that
pathology and you have to set that you
know amyloid pathologies one of the main
components of Alzheimer's disease you
should be able to improve cognition and
that's certainly not well accepted
everywhere there's probably other
components that were missing but these
are the models that we have available
and there is obviously a number of
problems with these models but there is
also a number of problems on how we
evaluate these models so if you look at
this table and sorry that it's kind of
small this is from a paper from Emma
burrows in Australia where she
summarized the findings of different
awesome results models and you see that
you know you should test different
aspects of cognition using conventional
types of testing you find the different
mouse models of Alzheimer's disease they
have issues with spatial memory issues
working memory and and maybe executive
function as well the problem is that if
you look at the literature it's really
complex because some people find this
deficit so it's gonna ages up there's
fine in later ages others do not find
assets for example if you look at the
very first one in the
some people have found that this is
facial memory
others have not found that is even in
very old mines and that's true for each
and every one of this Alzheimer's mouse
models and is really one of the problems
the fact that this conventional types of
behavior are very they're variable
between different labs so the most
common form of valuation in Alzheimer's
mouse models is the so-called Morris
water maze which has a strong component
of stress so my support in a pool of
water they have to figure out where they
can escape in a few days they kind of
remember where they can escape they
really don't like to be in the water and
they learn and then you test them if
they remember by removing where they
could escape and see whether they can
you know there's circulate around the
place where they could usually escape
from that platform well this is really
poorly translated to a human test if you
think about it so if you do a human test
you really don't get Alzheimer's
patients throw them in the pool and try
and ask them to figure out how to get
out so you do other types of tests of
spatial memory which do not involve all
that stress that the mice car and we
think this is a problem same thing for
the other types of tests that that
people use to evaluate information this
mice for example fear conditioning which
is not something that you really test in
Alzheimer's patients so there's an issue
in this how we do this testing and and I
grant you that sow is an issue in some
of the small small is that I'm not gonna
get into which relates to for example
the fact that they are overexpressed
human a pee pee so it's not a knocking
it's not the the gene in the mouth
that's been humanized as a transgenic
mice that overexpress other peptides in
addition to amyloid benefit they're like
better that I think there is different
promoters there are used insertion
places in the genome so there's really a
number of completely because we are
slowly this mouse models of the
Alzheimer's disease so I want to go to
some of my
you know if you will my dream if I'm
where to valuate mouse models of the
nation and the mention is really when
cognition in humans starts to affect the
inner ear activities of daily living and
it's really hard to do that in house but
you know ideally what you want to do is
is try to find probably the most
informative type of model for what you
wanna model and in that sense I really
like this phrase from from statistician
George box and he says that our models
are wrong but some are useful which
means that a lot of what I'm gonna tell
you today problem is wrong but some of
it is useful and I usually say that
because I have a lot of colleagues of
mine that come to me and said well we
know we cured Alzheimer's in mice number
of times where we can ask unions now we
cannot cure our genres in mice because
mice to not develop alzheimerís disease
Alzheimer's disease is a human disease
but we can model certain aspects of
pathology inflammation and cognitive
cognitive function in these mouse models
and then use that information to not
only understand disease but potentially
to use to use new drugs and deaths for
new drugs so this is the definition of
what the mention is I already mentioned
to you there is a new gene having
reproducibility of this conventional
tasks there was impact of the
experimenter ease of conventional tasks
for a man or a woman you may affect the
results that you have this farm and
genetic backgrounds all contribute to
this issue of reproducibility I
mentioned to you about translation of
this cognitive tasks you know they need
to be more similar to what you find in
humans another important aspect of this
cognitive testing is you'd like to
assess multiple mouse models and
multiple drugs at the same time
really dude is in a sort of
high-throughput type of testing you want
to automate automate automation of this
task you want to task that to be
standardized and in our hands what
really has worked is the use of the
touchscreen tasks for cognitive
assessment of mice and this really our
iPad like device that have been
developed by my colleagues team bossy
and Lisa succeeded when they were in
Cambridge in the UK they've now moved to
the University of Western area or we
have the Centre for the screen
technology use they developed probably
over 20 of those that screen asks for
different mouse models different aspects
off of cognition and and one of the
things that they have done in the last
few years and they've been invested
quite a lot of time expertise of this is
to really translate some of the stats to
human tasks so for this is an example of
a mouse that has been tested in a
specific test but also a human that's
taking the same test and this is a mouse
model of a mutation that causes
cognitive symptoms and and this is the
dlg to knockout mice they have issues
with this particular task which is
called a paired associates learning task
and when they tested humans they found
that control you know normal or humans
without that mutation can do this asked
quite well and I'm gonna show you how
this task worked but humans with the
same mutation that effects the mouse
performance also impairs the performance
of those humans in this particular task
so in the last few years we really
develop a high throughput pipeline and
we took advantage of the fact that is
this fast all not just the standard up
but they are automated and they provide
outputs they're really standardized and
we created this pipeline and we really
affect using this for near the
generations first and it
a number of different mouse models we
have the capacity to test about 500 mice
a day in different tasks we have the
capacity to do this also by recording
neurochemical changes recording neuron
our 50 changes I'm not going to talk
about this today but we automated this
process and and I'm going to show you
it's one of the projects that we
actually did some of these fasts and and
tasks with the same mouse models in
different labs so this is work that was
conducted by a number of trainees father
bear Aldo and Daniel Palmer and and and
and they've also contributed this this
was collaborate with papers at the
University of Guelph and then the whole
pipeline was automated afterwards by I
remember who's also here and in one of
the pictures and this was done in
collaboration my friends and colleagues
Jean vassilisa succeeded and and Vanya
Prado and it is that this mice go to
this automated touchscreen tasks we
collect the data we submit this data to
automated quality control and then this
all gets uploaded in an open science
open access database that people can
then go and download and we use these
datasets so the mouse models of
Alzheimer's disease that I'm gonna just
use as a proof of priests forth of the
experiments are the the some of the most
used mouse models of climbers disease
and we chose them because people have
tested them before in some of this test
screen tasks or they are widely used by
the community so this is the so called
super transgenic mouse model of
Alzheimer's disease that has both a PP
and and presenting mutations but also
has a cow mutation and has this the so
called amyloid plaques but also can form
this this hyper facilitated cow
pathology as well we also use the so
called five times FA D mouse model and
this has is a very perceived amyloid to
polish mouse model of Alzheimer's
as five mutations that increase Emilia
Genesis and they develop a full-blown
plaque by a few months three or four
months they have food on plants and
praying and by seven months they really
saturate it with plaques and finally we
used another mouse model that it's a
little bit less aggressive it takes a
little bit longer to develop designoid
pathology and and this is the ABP ps1
mouse model of Alzheimer's disease each
one of them in a different genetic
background uses controls the you know
animals of the same genetic background
they all came from jacks like people we
usually get to do some of those
experiments we we send this were sent
jiffy gloves so they would be tested in
different tasks and the different labs
and we also tested both male and female
mouse models of Alzheimer's disease so
the first task that I want to show you
is the fast that measures attention and
so is the five choice your reaction time
task that's developed by Traveller's and
collaborators in Cambridge a number of
these types of tasks were modeled in
human tasks that are part of the human
task of the cantab human tasks as well
and as I said there is there is quite a
few of those tasks that have been
developed to be used in humans as well
in this particular one the mice are
gonna see there's five windows that
represent individual stimulus this is a
very fast stimulus we increase
attentional demand by decreasing the
time that the light Islam to demise then
the mice have to respond by touching the
screen we really motivate mice by
providing them with a reward so there is
some strawberry shakin in strawberry
milkshake I quite like it and if they
get to do it right they get the reward
usually we food restrict as mice to make
sure that they are motivated to do this
fast and we train them to learn how to
use the touch screens that takes about a
month but then once they learn we can
probe this from time and time again and
we can probe attention by decreasing the
time
the slides is shown the screen and the
myspace click control and for one hour
day they go to this touchscreens and
they they get to play with the swings
and get some mr. berry milkshake as a
reward so it's the first video you will
see a mouse behaving in a touchscreen
well
[Music]
this type of test is being done for like
I said an hour several trials then
everything is collected by the computer
time to touch the screen time to collect
the reward and I just show you some of
some data sets so what are we looking
here is accuracy of mice and this is
control mice done in two different labs
so one one set of experiments was done
in my lab there on the other side of
experience was done at the University of
Guelph in three different ages and this
is accuracy so that's how many of 100%
got it right so in general if they we
don't tax attention if we do this
experiment with 1.5 seconds of flash of
light they get between 9 8 or 9 out of
10 right and if we decrease the flash of
possible from 1.5 to one-second 2.2 0.6
which is the last data point obviously
the accuracy decrease and the mice
doesn't get the right answer all the
time and that drops between 2 7 to 8 out
of 10 and what you can see is that there
is really an amazing revolutionary
between data sets they were acquired in
different labs for the wild-type mice if
you look in terms of and this was just
comparing for example now control mice
and and Alzheimer's mice you see that
also in a specific age I think this is
their older mice you also see quite a
bit of reproducibility between the data
sets and again this is you know data
sets obtaining into Finland and and this
is a second mouse model of Alzheimer's
disease and again comparing data sets
from control mice and the Alzheimer s
mice in different places and you see
that that you know it's quite impressive
I think if we measure all the different
pyramids that
can collect which usually it's an
enormous amount of data 85 to 90% of all
the parameters including times that the
screen time to collect the reward
all this data are are essentially
identical between different labs in
terms of effects of sex and genetic
background you can really pull out some
things so I don't have a mouse but in
the first set of graphs at the top we're
comparing females and males and again
different strains of mice and you see
that the painting on this train and some
some behave a little bit bear better but
in general all these trainings have the
same at least for the females we didn't
see any difference in the males we saw a
difference from one of these strains of
mice and this is in a younger age you
know older age we that difference
disappeared we did find for example for
one strain one background strain that
was used that they have way more
premature responses that we could detect
both for male and female mice that's the
green strain that is shown here in the
second set of graphs in the middle and
the last set of graphs and bottom we're
comparing again the responses accuracy
that we measure between male and female
mouse models both control and transgenic
mouse models at early age and they don't
have a lot of pathology in a later age
and you can see that is it you know it's
really quite remarkable and the male and
female behaved essentially the same in
this particular task just some data sets
for you to see what you could use this
information for so so for example this
is a work that's been published using
the same type of touchscreen tasks with
the triple transgenic mouse model of
disease this was published by my
colleagues in baepsae and this is
succeeded in 2011 they use a different
background than what we use and if they
detected a attention that's where the
Alzheimer's mouse model had an attained
dassit and they they just tested this
where the mice were 11 months they
tested only male mice obviously we we
did this high throughput testing and we
find that both male and female triple
transgenic mouse models have annotation
there so we could reproduce this that's
it's that they had found out before but
even more interesting not only
reproduced this when the mice were in
the same age that they detected this
changes but we could see changes much
earlier on when when the mice were 3 to
6 months old which is really important
if you wanna not wait too long to start
testing drugs to improve cognition
another example of what I would like to
show you is a mouse model of cholinergic
which is function this is our mice that
we generate in my own lab so as probably
most of you know the basal forebrain is
one of the main groups of cells that
have been affected there are effected in
Alzheimer's disease and humans and there
is a dysfunction in the basal forebrain
there is this function in the
cholinergic system we can reproduce this
dysfunction just leaving again another
data set that this is quite interesting
so if you look at this mouse model 3
poster genic of Alzheimer's disease what
you can see is that in the first graph
is that when you treat with a drug that
is used in humans as2 cholinesterase
inhibitor which is used in humans you
can't improve the performance of the
alzheimer's mouse model and you get the
alzheimer's mouse model to not perform
as a control mice we did a different
experiment now we got we used this mice
that have no release of us 2 : in the
cortex and in hippocampus so we target
the visitors to : transporter which is a
gene that is decreased that expression
of which is decrease in Alzheimer's
disease and what you can see in this
mouse model is that they really are very
poor to perform in this attention that
we pass so the lower red
line is mutant mice and they really
perform in the worse that we ever seen
they get maybe four or five out of ten
right
where's control mice can get you know in
eight or seven at six
and they also make a lot of mistakes
they sometimes don't engage in a meet
and so pretty much showing that if you
don't have ownership function you affect
the performance in this particular task
this is a second task that I really
think is interesting for Alzheimer's
disease so it's paired associate
learning here the mice needs to match an
image to a location so they always see
two images but just one of them is in
the right location so if you look at
this there is a flower and a plane in
the first row the flower is right
because it's the right location in the
last row there is a again a flower in a
plane but now the plane is right because
it's in the right location so for the
sake of time we're just gonna play just
one more or two more movies for just to
show how this guys work can we play the
movie two and three now
you
and if we look at the data for this you
see the control mice get seven or eight
out of ten right where is this mutant
mice that have the same sort of
cholinergic deficits as Alzheimer's
patients they really get maybe five six
out of ten right when they're really
what so showing they have a lot of
problems so we did some control
experiments so this is a mouse model
that we we again made a deletion of this
visitors to Poland transporter but we
deleted from other cholinergic neurons
the cholinergic neurons that projected
the talent was not to the cortex and and
what you see here is that this guy eyes
came from absolutely normal as the
control mice and this particular paired
associate learning task one of
interesting aspects is when we tested
all this different mouse models of
Alzheimer's disease we found in all of
them some sort of death set using this
particular task suggesting that you know
this might be an interesting test and is
used in humans to differentiate between
mild cognitive impairment and potential
to develop Alzheimer's disease and
people that don't have cognitive
deficits so I'm gonna run the left
it's very task I'm gonna jump off I'm
not gonna show the movie for this one
this is a pairwise visual discrimination
and reversal learning and is used to you
know first to access the ability to
discriminate different pairs of images
but also to test for behavior
flexibility so what the mice has to do
here is they're shown two sets of images
and they learn one of them is going to
give the reward in this case the one
labeled in green and then when they get
to be really good and get nine out of
ten right we do when we go and switch
the Keynesians and now these guys we
only get a reward if they touch they are
the one obviously the performance goes
down and they have to relearn the task
and that's measures behavior flexibility
I'm gonna jump from this me show the
movie now I'm just gonna show you that
at least for the three out summers mouse
models that we tested we really didn't
see
a lot of behavior flexibility deserts
either with male or female mice and
that's summer I want to show you that
and this again that mouse model that
really doesn't release us to : in the in
the forebrain and you can see that they
actually can learn to do the tap and and
to see the blue error on the top is
where the mice got to be you know about
eighty or nine out of ten right so
they're really well trained and then we
do a little bit of a baseline four times
baseline and then we switch the
conditions and that's when the graph
drops and then now their their
percentage were correct or accuracy goes
down to less than ten twenty percent and
you see that everybody starts in the
same way but control mice learn and they
go back to performing at eighty or
ninety percent correct choices whereas
the mice that have released no as you
hold in the brain they have really hard
time to figuring out that reversal of
the roost unless we treat these guys
with coal master inhibitors would
improve or or would improve cognitive
function and then we can rescue that
that's it that we observed in the mutant
mice that don't be from above chance
level so just to show you the power of
the technology in testing for drugs and
testing for cognitive this high level
cognitive dysfunction in mouse models so
what do you do with this like I said all
the data you obtain is we under guys so
what we did was to create a two set of
information sharing one that shares
knowledge and that's really the
brainchild by calling team bossy where
and we call this touchscreen cognition
the org that's a forum for discussion we
publish standard operating procedures
people can log in to get there there is
a social media like platform where you
can see what the recent work has been
published we called the wall people can
discuss people can ask questions for
eggs
birds in the field and you can you know
discuss your experiments if the men in
your experiments and how you can do this
way that can get you meaningful data but
we also developed a data repository
where you can actually get the data that
comes out of the stud screens and it
doesn't have to be only the touch
screens we work with we iterated
software that allows every type of that
screen to be uploaded you know we just
need to run scripts to get the same sort
of data sets that we use for the data
repository we call this mouse bites this
is a paper that was published late
December in life and and basically what
it does it allows you to upload your
data sets if it's quality control
assessment automated quality control
assessment collects a lot of metadata as
well and that allows you to then search
these data sets download this data sets
we use this data set we have
visualization and and I really urge you
to go there I'm gonna show you I'm gonna
give you the website for this you can
have you can visualize data that are
there you can have your data set as
public or private if it's private owned
you see it if it's public everybody sees
it and once the data are published as
public then they really open licence and
you know people can reuse this data and
reanalyze this data there's a number of
really very interesting features of this
software if you are downloading the data
you don't really need to log in but if
you are going to upload you need to be
identified your lab to be identified
your datasets you can create different
experiments you can use several
different types of touchscreen tests all
have automated quality control you
identify your animals you can get in
datasets for individual or animals we
have really some amazing features for
example let's say you generate a figure
for a paper a panel of a figure for a
paper you can create a hyperlink
that allows people to just click and get
the data set for that particular panel
on that particular figure so there is
really a number of very interesting
features you can download all the data
sets as CSV files and use you know your
your extender type soft unwise and
generate people tables and do reduce
statistics and really the drive be from
the drive for this is the open access
movement so you know we try to follow
the fare principles of findability
accessibility interfere ability so the
datasets can be read by humans and
machines and and obviously the idea is
that people will get people to reuse
these data sets and and and reanalyze
this data sets and right now I think we
have about 1,300 individual mice the
past or reading fights from multiple
labs and it is that's for example if you
want to test or you want to know a
specific background of this specific
genetic background affects performance
you're going to be able to go in the
data set and compare the different
genetic backgrounds compare male-female
but you're not comparing just 10 mice
who are probably only comparing hundreds
of mice from different labs and being
able to compare it with disability how
well data shows from different labs and
etc and and the principle here is really
working together and I think this this
cartoon of two donkeys trying to find
food work really well whether you know
either we work together to really solve
this major gaps in knowledge in drug
discovery for Alzheimer's disease and
other types of dementia or we're not
gonna have much chance to really make
major discoveries and so this will be
open science initiatives that we have
screen cognition dot-org you can assess
this is the web address for that
particular web platform where you can
share knowledge you can ask questions
you can participate in a in this
community there is about 300 labs in the
world that you
this touchscreen technology there is a
number of farmer that used that screen
technology that you really hoped to
convince everybody to be part of this
community and grow this community and by
the way we do run a course for
touchscreen testing every year and just
you know check on the website and people
who are in the stats screen cognition
you'll be able to attend the course for
for free breeder sharing is Mouse bite
so that's the way I've address from
Mouse why would you to go there and
check Mouse provides Donal data looking
visualize some of the datasets I didn't
have time to show you and and and and
you know just really take advantage of
of learning how to do better more open
and more reliable cognitive testing or
measures of success for this project is
really increasing reproducibility in
behavior testing you in rodents in
particular house models of disease we do
hope to convince a lot of different
users and go from a thousand mice to 10
200 thousands of mice eventually we like
to see some crowdsourcing and people
were using not just reusing the data but
doing novel types of analysis maybe
confirming or maybe disputing some of
the interpretations that some of us have
have reached with this datasets we won
increase access to open data create a
platform for drug testing what do you
combine the right mouse model the right
cognitive testing and that can be used
to screen like I said we do test five
hundred miles a day and obviously this
would allow us to synergize efforts for
improving preclinical testing and
hopefully very better the drugs that go
to clinical trials and be able to tell
with a little bit more confidence that
these drugs are could be able to improve
certain cognitive tests that are
translatable to humans so I'm going to
finish by thanking the people that
really did this
so father Aldo and that used to be in my
lab did a lot of this work sir memory
has developed the mouse bytes platform
then your Palmer did a lot of the
analyses that I showed you today and so
did
Penkala snake that did some of these
fragments in mouse models of colon areas
function also work from Ornella sake kin
in lineage any cava on the mouse models
of Canaries function this work was done
in collaboration with my colleague boy
winters at the University of Guelph and
at the University of Western area is
really being amazing to collaborate with
my partner and wife of Anna Prada for
the last 25 30 years and and more
recently in the last five years we have
been very fortunate to have elesif
accident impasse moving from Ambridge
and coming to Western and really
creating this helping to create this
this amazing platform and the Center for
the technology and of course we cannot
do this unless we get some funding and
some of the funding particularly Western
brain Institute's in the beginning and
more recently for the support of mouths
bytes this there is a Canadian
initiative at Western we're funded by
the Canadian government for cognition
and that's where Western brain scan a
program that has supported the this open
science initiatives and in a number of
other agents in the past and and
currently as well and I'll be happy to
answer any questions you can email me
and and we go from there
thank you very much for attending this
conference and I'll see you in the next